Якщо ви опинились на вулиці під час
ядерного вибуху ваша задача перша - це
вберегтись чисто фізично від вибухової
та світлової хвилі для цього потрібно
впасти за бордюр зайти за кут будівлі за
якісь фізичний важкий об'єкт у жодному
разі не дивіться на спалах бо він може
обпекти рогівку очей чи засліпити після
обох хвиль є максимум 10 хвилин часу щоб
знайти укриття і не постраждати від
радіації яка почне осідати найкращим
варіантом буде спеціальне сховище з
герметичними дверима і фільтраційною
системою у вентиляції або ж підземні
станції метро для того щоб забезпечити
людей від негативного впливу ядерного
вибуху
радіоактивно забруднення радіаційне
опромінення
на станції використовуються металеві
конструкції так називаємо так звані
затвори Ось Він знаходиться перед вами
відкриваються металеві щити і затвор
піднімається знизу вверх і перекриває
весь
оцей прийом це не дозволяє радіоа
ктивним А якщо за цей час не вдасться
провести розбір за балів та дезактивацію
території термін продовжить до чотирьох
на самих станціях є автономні джерела
електроживлення та водопостачання навіть
при відсутності зовнішнього
електроживлення на станції буде
подаватися електрожила для роботи
освітлення ескалаторів систем
повітропостачання і насосі для того щоб
подавались вода тобто вода на станції з
артезіанської свердло він буде
повітря буде проходити як через
спеціальний фільтр і очищатися і
подаватися на станцію вже очищеним каже
що такого сховища Поблизу немає укритися
треба у будь-якому приміщенні вдома в
офісі чи навіть в магазині головне
правильно його герметизувати
що мається на увазі закрити всі прийоми
віконні
заклеїти їх скотчем забити вентиляцію
ганчірками скотчем папером ще чимось щоб
не було повітря оновлення повітря тому
що якщо вентиляцію щось виходить це
означає що воно Вашу квартиру вашого
оселю ваше сховище звідкись підсосуються
і буде підсосуватись звісно радіоактивне
повітря там треба мати бутильовану воду
та їжу яка не контактувала із зовнішнім
середовищем а поточну воду краще взагалі
не вживати якщо ряту військові служби
цього не дозволили такі дії вбережуть
від Альфа та бета-чинок а от
гама-випромінювання проходить Навіть
через бетон і цеглу тому найкраще
перечекати за якомога більшою кількістю
стін ми будемо проводити оповіщення
населення Як говорив казати про те що
треба робити в цій чи іншій ситуації
будь-яке сховище яке вже і казав буде
бути буде являтися захистом від
радіаційного випромінювання ми знаємо з
вами прекрасно що будь-який будівельний
конструкції вже значно зменшують силу в
радіаційного випромінювання і Чим довші
стани тим буде тим буде краще
підготувати свою тривожну валізу мати
індивідуальні засоби захисту мати речі
які можна буде наприклад якісь плач який
можна буде помити або провести його
санітарну обробку для того щоб мене
принести на себе ці радіаційні елементи
найбезпечнішими будуть квартири чи офіси
на середніх поверхах бо радіоактивні
опади випадають на дах і на землю Якщо ж
ядер вибух стався далеко від вас треба
моніторити напрямок вітру через
спеціальні додатки або сайт
укргідрометцентру якщо вона Ми на вас Де
Ви знаходитесь є сенс прорахувати час за
який це радіоактивне повітря досягне вас
і якщо у вас є час для того щоб
евакуюватись перпендикулярно ці
атмосфері є сенс це зробити але тільки
не їхати в сторону від вибуху тому що у
вас буде накривати постійно це
наздоганяти і накривати радіоактивну
атмосферу тільки перпендикулярно чи
право чи вліво це найкоротша відстань
яку ви подолаєте для того щоб виїхати з
зони ураження у сховищі треба просидіти
мінімум добу а щоб виїхати із
забрудненої території потрібно мати
засоби захисту окуляри для очей
респіратори для органів дихання і
закрити всі ділянки тіла на кожному із
цих засобів обов'язково повинен бути
прописаний стандарт на ньому вказані усі
речовини згідно розшифровки
з яким з якими можна працювати в цих
рукавичках на ньому вказано що вони є
противірусні і що важливо тут вказується
421 стандарт який є стандартом що може
бути застосований при роботі з
обмеженою кількістю людей активного
матеріалу Тобто це часточки це якась
невелика кількість матеріалу але це в
жодному разі не опромінені тобто від
опромінення товару такого Ну він буде
коштувати по-перше дуже дорого по-друге
Він зазвичай постачається в першу чергу
для військових
щоб обмежити контакт шкіри і слизової із
радіоактивними частинками пилу руки
найкраще захистити щільними рукавичками
з однорідного матеріалу для органів
дихання взяти фільтр третього рівня
захисту напівмазку або повнолицьову
маску і одягнути на себе одноразовий
комбінезони із проклеєними швами Та
треба пам'ятати такі засоби можуть лише
мінімізувати контакт із Альфа та бета-
частинками Тобто це споживчий або
Індустріальний товар Він не є товаром
класу cbrm так А клас сибіренца якраз
таки той товар про який ми зараз
говоримо це за конкретно радіаційний
хімічний біологічний ядерний захист щодо
вживання йоду треба бути обережними під
час використання тактичної ядерної зброї
відсоткова частинка радіоактивного йоду
маленька тому таблетка може лише
нашкодити організмові людям після 40
років в принципі взагалі немає сенсу
пити Це його тому що він пригнічує дуже
багато органів зуби сустави нирки і все
і інше але так він насичує щитовидну
залозу його її сенс використовувати
тільки там дітям молодим особам у яких
До сих пір продовжується процес
поділення клітин тобто вони зростають
для того щоб блокувати ймовірно
негативну дію радіоактивного йоду
дорослим йод варто вживати лише в разі
аварії на атомній станції і те якщо
знаходитися близько Про подальші дії
будуть сповіщати рятувальники зв’язок
пропаде але працюватиме аналогове радіо
тому краще мати таке вдома але
ймовірність аварії на атомній станції Чи
тактичний ядерний удар по Україні
експерти вважають малоймовірним береги
не використання цієї зброї десь не в
густонаселених містах не в Києві не у
Львові десь по периметру лінії
зіткнення Можливо там на Чорному морі
для того щоб запустити та подивитися на
реакцію світу як цивілізований світ
відреагує на ці дикунські абсолютно дії
Росії та якщо Росія наважиться
застосувати ядерну зброю треба
загерметизуватися і чекати вказівок від
ДСНС тоді шанси не лише вижити а й
залишитися здоровими будуть дуже
високими